i'm kennedy i'm bill hemmer i'm harris
faulkner and this is the fox news
rundown
friday march 25th 2022 i'm lisa brady
the u.s and its allies are keeping up
the pressure on russia but the war in
ukraine is just one crisis on a lengthy
list if the world were an emergency room
the biden white house is in triage mode
we speak with fox's dana parino
i'm chris foster chef jose andres and
his team are serving more than 200 000
meals a day to ukrainians forced to
leave their homes all the europe and all
the world should be with ukrainian
people that they are going to work for
that has no reason to exist the least we
can be doing is that the people going
through this mayhem at the very least
can be fed
and i'm will kane and i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's a milestone many military experts
didn't think was possible today marks
one month since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine but it's been a
month of fierce resistance with russia
largely unable to advance despite the
mast mass devastation and hardship it's
causing president biden spent the day
with other world leaders in a trio of
emergency summits including a nato
meeting where ukrainian president
volodymerzelinski made another appeal
via video link for more weapons still
asking for planes and tanks
to save people in our cities ukraine
needs military assistance without
restrictions russia is using its entire
arsenal against us also warning again
that russia's goal isn't just ukraine
and what if russia turns to chemical
weapons we would respond we would
respond if he uses it the nature of the
response would depend on the nature of
the use as more sanctions were announced
president biden also telling reporters
in brussels sanctions weren't meant to
deter president putin that the most
important thing is to maintain sanctions
and unity that after a month we will
sustain what we're doing not just next
month the following month but for the
remainder of this entire year that's
what will stop him he says nato has
never been more united well a couple of
things one it looks like there are a
couple of countries in europe that are
going a little wobbly on the sanctions
dana perino is co-anchor of america's
newsroom on fox news channel co-host of
the five and a former white house press
secretary for president george w bush
for example france they are doing the
sanctions but they're doing a ton of
other business with russia still and i
would imagine at the g7 leaders meeting
that this will come up that they need to
be unified also even for us our energy
sanctions don't go into place until june
24th so putin can withstand a lot of
pain besides he's not personally hurting
he doesn't care about his people that's
obvious
so i think that he is willing to take a
lot of pain the other thing is he did
something kind of interesting he said
anyone wanting to buy oil and gas from
russia is going to have to pay in rubles
why would he do that well because he
knows his financial system is under a
tremendous amount of strain and our
country's going to want to change their
currency into rubles in order to buy his
oil and gas i think that could backfire
on him and
i think that something that is not
changing his mind is that he doesn't
care
about the people
either the ukrainians or his own people
he doesn't mind if they suffer he's got
a very
different mindset than all of us
how much does united front on sanctions
enforcement
matter well without it it doesn't matter
because like i mean are we putting
enough pressure on countries that are
willing to help putin in any way i i
think that we'll have to see do you
remember when we first put the sanctions
forward about three weeks ago biden said
we'll see where we are in a month and we
all thought what do you mean a month
that seems so far away we need to know
right away these people are dying but
he had a longer-range view and he was
probably right on that right so now we
are a month into the war today and
the ukrainians are holding off the
russians better than anybody thought
they might more weapons are coming to
help the ukrainians it's still a very
precarious situation and putin has he
doesn't want to just take over ukraine
he's demolishing it some of these
beautiful cities are gone they're
reduced to rubble
there is still kind of a debate about
giving fighter jets to ukraine not
directly from the us
this is all something americans are
paying a lot of attention to 63 percent
in a new fox news poll say the u.s
should be doing more to help ukrainians
fight russia more than half in the
survey said they would support a no-fly
zone
has the bide administration had the
right balance handling putin so far well
if on the migs in particular it's very
curious one i think that
poland was ready to do it it seemed like
it had been signed off by everybody
including the secretary of state and
then it goes to the president at the
white house and he pulls it back now he
might have good reason to do that and
perhaps in the future we'll be able to
find out exactly what those reasons were
but zielinski and his military believe
that they need the migs in order to
protect
people from being shelled from up above
without them they say that they can't do
it now nato and the countries that are
um supportive are saying well we'll
provide you weapons and here's some
tanks like we don't want tanks we want
the missiles so perhaps at this meeting
of the mines
nato can come together and decide what
is actually needed and what can we be
what can be provided as quickly as
possible because time is of the essence
i wanted to ask you about white house
messaging because you've worked in a
white house in a time of crisis
how hard is it to thread that needle
when you have to consider not only the
american people and the media but also
allies and enemies with what you're
saying oh i love this question the
president that i worked for president
bush used to describe it to me as any
president at any time is talking to five
audiences especially when there's a
foreign policy issue involved one is
your ally
two is your adversary
three of the american people
for
the citizens of the other countries
and five your own military
wow and sometimes you want to say
something that will make the american
people like you more
but it will sound off or wrong to your
military or it might complicate
something for one of your allies or your
adversary might take it the wrong way so
there's a there's a lot that goes into
the communication i sort of felt like
one of the things that would be
effective is when putin is going on and
on about the reuniting of the ukrainian
and
just like this really weird distorted
view of history is to have a one word
answer from president biden
enough
and leave it at that
and let them guess what that means
it has to be frustrating for any white
house though
if you're getting criticism on action or
inaction
and maybe you're doing more than people
think but you can't actually talk about
all of that sure and they should not be
talking about all of it i'm super
sympathetic to that and admiral kirby at
the press um the press secretary at the
pentagon i think does a very good job
and the other thing he said
the other day admiral kirby said
trust me we are doing things we cannot
tell you about
and when you see that the ukrainians
they might not be winning but they're
not losing
i think that we have to believe him when
he says that
every white house faces some headwinds
um
is it fair to say this one is facing
more challenges than most i mean this is
there are
so many if this
if the world were an emergency room
the biden white house is in triage mode
you have multiple crises happening all
at once and we we're talking about
russia and ukraine we also have this
issue where they're trying to finalize a
deal with the iranians who are then
showing off their weapons
and suggesting that their irgc doesn't
need to be in the terrorism
group anymore
you have this the truth of the matter is
there's a famine that's coming
and we all know it because the wheat
can't get out of russia and ukraine and
there's not enough fertilizer in order
to feed the world and if you remember
the arab spring that wasn't just about
twitter
wheat prices had gone through the roof
people were hungry and when people are
hungry there will be uprisings and when
there are uprisings there's also
emigration and people try to leave to
get somewhere else
so there's all of those problems i
didn't even mention our southern border
oh should we talk about china there's
that issue over there as well
there are so many issues that are going
on on the just on the foreign policy
front and so many people that are in the
president's party they just want to talk
about domestic issues
and they have pulled the president quite
far to the left and which is why
one the president is looking at historic
losses
when it comes to the midterm elections
and they they're not going to be able to
get a lot done between now and then
and then we're off to the races for
2024.
so they have headwinds but i think that
because things are so precarious right
now and national security is so
important they have to focus on that and
not worry about the elections or about
the poll numbers they have to do what
they think is right and let the chips
fall where they may then of course we
have the high inflation which is both
domestic and and global excuse me i
didn't even mention that part yet
the famine has been on my mind but the
energy prices they're hitting absolutely
everybody especially the low income
and then
you know the white house umbrella over
all these things is it's either pandemic
related or it's putin's fault a lot
is that holding water with voters
no
and you look at something like the
meeting that president biden had before
he went to europe
with the business roundtable
where jamie dimon the ceo of jp morgan
implored the president to create a
marshall plan
for natural gas energy production so
when you have one of the biggest
democratic donors
who runs one of the biggest financial
institutions in the world
telling you that you need to have a
marshall plan for energy and oil
exploration
there might be some changes
but that would be where biden needs to
say
we can
do more oil and gas production while we
try to transition to greener energy but
we have to do this now and he's going to
have to buck that left side of his party
while the president was in europe the
senate judiciary committee was wrapping
up confirmation hearings for supreme
court nominee katanji brown jackson who
spent quite a bit of time tuesday and
wednesday defending sentencing decisions
especially in child pornography cases
while fielding questions from republican
senators including missouri's josh
hawley the government asked for
enhancements why didn't you apply the
enhancements as they were asked for
senator i've answered this question many
times from many senators who've asked me
so i'll stand on what i've already said
judge jackson says her decisions have
been based on factors beyond sentencing
guidelines that she weighs the evidence
differentiates among defendants and that
her sentences have been in line with
most of her colleagues given that
democrats have the votes to confirm her
were republicans using the hearings to
help set the stage on some midterm
issues and was that a wise thing to do i
mean it's hard to imagine that a supreme
court nominee's hearings in march will
be top of mind come november however
there are issues about
crime that are going to be on the ballot
and also about parents and parents
involvement and children with their
children
i think that the republicans know that
katanji brown jackson has the votes
i think they did what they could the
best they could i do think that
i'm not one to harp on media bias but
when it comes to judicial nominations it
is so stark to me
how republican nominees are treated in
the media versus democratic nominees
it's just unbelievable
democrats are considered passionate for
asking tough questions republicans are
considered attack dogs for doing the
same thing i mean she would be of course
making his she's already made history
just by being nominated she has made
history she will make history as a
supreme court justice and
it's premature to congratulate her but i
think that it is not lost on me that
this is a
significant historical moment
we lost a historic figure this week to
say the least um madeleine albright
highest ranking woman in u.s government
history at the time when she became
president bill clinton's secretary of
state
i loved that the
official statement from president biden
on her passing
mentioned her collection of pins
what was it like to know her and to
spend any time behind the scenes with
her
she was such a woman of strength and
dignity and grace and i loved that
combination she was quite blunt when she
had earned the right to be she believed
in america fiercely
and in liberty and democracy and freedom
and for fighting for the little guy
as she did during
the serbian war when she went to bill
clinton and said we need to get involved
so
i love the fact that she had used her
pins as a way to communicate to the
world she was artistic she was a mom
just an incredible woman i was honored
to know her i didn't know her as well as
some other people like jillian turner
here at fox news actually got her first
job from madeleine albright but one of
my favorite stories is that the first
woman secretary of state who was an
immigrant to our country madeline
albright her family fled the nazis
her dad got a job as a professor of
international relations at the
university of denver and a few years
later who becomes his student
but
secretary condoleeza rice
and it's a lovely story how that all
came full circle
wow
layers of history
um dana preno always a pleasure
co-anchor of america's newsroom on fox
news channel also co-host of the five
and i want to mention season two
of your podcast everything will be okay
is available starting monday you can
find that at fox news podcasts
thank you for spending some of your time
with us loved it thank you
[Music]
this is will kane with your fox news
commentary coming up
i'm chris foster the united nations says
about 10 million ukrainians a quarter of
the population have left their homes
since the start of the russian invasion
a month ago some have left the country
some are still in ukraine in cities
considered more safe at least for now
they need a place to stay and of course
they need to eat jose andres is helping
with that the chef and restaurant owner
has a non-profit organization called
world central kitchen that provides
meals to people in need due to crises
like natural disasters and in this case
war
as soon as we saw the first
bombs and the attack
began
by the russians
washington kitchen team landed here he
spoke with us from levi ukraine from
there we've expanded across six
countries obviously we're inside ukraine
in more than 19 20 cities probably a few
more by now we are now in countries like
spain where i am from in madrid where
there is a refugee uh ukrainian refugee
welcoming center where we are there 24 7
also
feeding
people we are doing more or less around
200 000 meals right now and the number
keeps it increasing as the shelters
become sometimes slightly bigger every
day right right um how do you even know
where to go in a situation like this
it's not like
where it's not it's not so centralized
is there coordination with with local
governments what's the infrastructure
for these people being taken care of
well remember we are restaurant people
we're chefs we're cooks and we have it
in our blood not waiting to be called
but to find the people
when
our modus operandis is food people
restaurants
farmers who knows better any city than
chefs and restaurant owners
we get information on the flag it's a
train stations that need food those are
very obvious in the border when people
are waiting on the buses sometimes for
hours like in the early days sometimes
for days five six days we we
we learn by having something is very
important and everybody forgets nobody
being on a room planning but by dealing
with boots on the ground and scouting
the situation that's why we are in more
than 750 delivery places because since
day one the thing we've been doing is
let's start cooking let's start bringing
food with us let's start scouting a lot
of times in these situations
international food aid might be okay
here's some bags of flour here's some
military ready to eat meals you're
trying to do something to care for these
people and make them feel cared for
well i mean at the end of the day how
many restaurants are there in the in
planet earth we're talking about
millions and millions of restaurants
obviously if this was a hurricane like
in bahamas where the northern islands
were totally wiped out and was no one
place to cook there we will build our
own big kitchen here we have our kitchen
north uh 20 minutes from mavick in the
town of shimish where we have a huge
kitchen that we can do five hundred
thousand minutes a day if we have to but
everywhere else we use food trucks
catering companies restaurant partners
that they become our friends we support
them we know how we support them
obviously financially we support them in
any way we can get in the food but right
now the food in obviously poland romania
moldova
slovakia hungary in the places we are
all across is no issue with food inside
ukraine i mean
if you come with me to the supermarkets
the supermarkets have food if you come
with me to restaurants where right now i
can see one the
the restaurant is is full with people
having dinner people having coffee it's
kind of this situation where in la vie
things is not a war in ukraine and we
know that we are receiving photos by
partners in places like turkey and
others that they are under shelling or
they are under bombing this is the
situation we live in ukraine that
somehow looks like nothing is happening
in the beast until we don't hear the
alarms going up because a missile may be
coming and all of a sudden not too few
hundred kilometers away people are dying
in the front lines this is how crazy a
war may be in our country yeah i mean
and then some of them are dying of
dehydration they're dying of starvation
and maripo when you see these people
filing through not filing through but
when you're your guests
what are you hearing from them what are
you seeing in their faces is it is it
relief is it
some residual terror
and
yesterday night um i was checking our
operations in medic and was this woman
that
she was carrying a very big piece of
luggage
the woman was older brawling her 70s
as you could see that she had no more
tears
to give but still she was crying is this
kyle's amazing crazy situation that
breaks your heart
we got very quickly obviously a
translator and the message was i lost my
son my son died
this is the situation you find when you
see a children that when you're giving
them a plate of food to a sandwich or
candy the first thing they tell you my
dad stay behind
when you cross and you see sometimes
that the fathers or the brothers are the
ones driving their family to the border
and they say goodbye
not to make it dramatic but we know that
goodbye means a lot of things because
those young men are going back with only
one idea to defend their country and
when you see those moments those
goodbyes
kind of you really
cannot help but have a tier or two
because you are suffering in a way like
them even you cannot understand what
they are going through this is the many
situations you will face in the border
or in land inside the train
um you've been in dangerous situations
before but not like this never you've
never tried to activate to be activated
in an active war zone um but like you
said levi is this sort of bastion of
peace but are you concerned that lev
could be next
last week when i was here in the la viva
as i was leaving and i was getting on my
plane i saw this sequence of missiles
that hit a few kilometers outside the
city of la vie very close to the border
with poland all of the sudden you
realize that the war is moving
west
uh obviously not the same as kiev is
suffering another
another cities but uh what you do is
making sure that you have good systems
in place that you don't put anybody in
monday than necessary but this is the
reality
the war is fought many ways we are an
organization of peace we're
organizational feeding and what we are
very proud is to know that there are
earthquakes many of them could be away
from their restaurant away from their
city they could be in the safety of one
country that is welcoming them they
could be working in another restaurant
somewhere in europe
but those men and women decide to stay
to keep doing what they know best which
is to gather the food
to light the kitchen in any way or form
they can to start cooking and start
seeing anybody that is in need well in a
shelter well in a tunnel where in a
neighborhood
this is what breaks uh gives me a little
bit of your is to know that those men
and women are doing it and the least we
can be doing as well central kitchen is
to be near them organizing the system
organizing the food making sure that
when we can they receive track loads
full of fruit and non-perishable so they
can keep feeding their people which
right now they are our people all the
europe and all the world should be with
ukrainian people that they are going
through a workforce that has no reason
to exist the least we can be doing is
that the people going through this
mayhem at the very least can be fed and
can be receiving water even we know some
people are having a hard time right now
uh getting those things i've spoken with
chefs before
um who said they got into this just for
the the love of the love of feeding
people this very fundamental thing
and what you're doing obviously is
taking that to a much bigger level did
you feel that as a kid growing up that
you just is this why you wanted to cook
listen um i think everybody forgets that
i don't want to get to romanticize here
but the first gift in a tangible form
that we receive
as humans in the moment we're born is is
food
when our mothers brings us close to
their bodies and feeds us
and even if we are highly unaware i
think that moment that moment seals
the connection between humans and food
that food is is a moment of goodness
that food is a moment of saying you're
welcome that food is something you may
share with a stranger that food is this
moment that you say longer tables will
win the day and higher walls have no
space
and
why i do what i do because is what
everybody does
what do you do with the people you love
for the new new people you meet you
invite them to restaurant or even better
you buy them home you see them in your
table and you break bread my friend
that's why i do what i do but that's
what very much every single chef in
ukraine right now and let me tell you in
pola in romania i want to say thank you
to the hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people that in a very
unselfish way
in the moment that refugees were leaving
ukraine and crossing into their cities
from firefighters to school teachers to
retire military all began cooking all
began giving diapers so giving blankets
so whatever was needed to take care of
this crisis the people that helped these
refugees from the beginning were not the
very big organizations were not the
the un was not the european community
was everyday citizens
taking lead and taking care of people in
need and to all of them my biggest run
of applause because i've been here and
i've seen it in first person they are to
me the other heroes of this crisis
when you get back to the us after
missions like this does it take a while
for it not to seem a little
inconsequential a little silly to get
back to the fancy restaurant life
well i mean i'm one person every we have
now hundreds and hundreds of volunteers
i have a lot of people that came from
different parts of the world that are
volunteering with us in different
situations and everybody obviously has a
moment right yesterday it was the
birthday of my daughter and i'm gonna
miss it and
very soon it's gonna be
a very important moment of my other
daughter is a big graduation moment and
i think i'm gonna miss it
and unlike me
we have
millions right now for ukrainians that
they are not only missing those
important moments but that they don't
have loved ones already because they are
they are dead
because they lost
their homes because they are already on
the ruins
uh so yes it puts in perspective
what life is right
i always say that what must be good for
me must be good for others
andreas i'm sure your daughters are very
proud of you and i'm sure you'll make it
up to them when you when you're able to
get home jose founder of the non-profit
world central kitchen thank you very
much for talking to us thank you for
having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to tyrus and tim
every week fox nation host tyrus and fox
news contributor kat tim give their hot
takes explore weird headlines and share
amusing stories subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the medical professionals at orlando
health arnold palmer hospital for
children have a new co-worker who goes
by the name of parks parks is a
two-year-old golden retriever and is the
only facility dog at arnold palmer
kimberly burbidge is a child life
specialist there helping kids cope with
being in the hospital and she told me
she's been interested in starting a
program like this for several years
she's also park's handler and says parks
works with patients alongside her some
of them are chronic patients who maybe
just need that extra support kind of
that judgment-free
love that dogs can give everyone
he can help work as motivation for some
of our kids so if we have a child for
example who is struggling to meet their
goals that by their physical therapists
or by their physicians parks can kind of
work alongside them parks is a graduate
from k-9 companions a non-profit group
that trains canines to be service dogs
and facility dogs he had two years of
training before joining the hospital and
knows more than 40 commands which
kimberly says they're using to
accomplish physical therapy tasks for
the patients we've been working on him
to get into a wagon and that way the
children can pull him around in the
wagon which might be helpful for anyone
but especially some of our kids who
really need to move around that are kind
of not wanting to they build on commands
to accomplish things like the wagon pool
so that command we built from jump which
would be him jumping into the wagon and
then sit which would be him sitting down
and then a stay so that way he stays
right in that nice sit-up position and
then our patients can pull him around
parkes also knows how to push elevator
buttons open automatic doors and the
kids even get to walk him we'll hook up
a second leash to parks and then they
can walk the dog with me holding parks
and with miley to be under control of it
then also they get to hold their leash
and walk him around the unit she says
he's also been helpful in reducing
anxiety they love everyone so it's a
very non-judgmental time it's very
calming time so just that rhythmic
petting sometimes can help with anxiety
and help support them best of luck to
parks in his new job and to the kids
he's working with tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind leah thomas didn't
win the women's 500 freestyle at the
ncaa championships because leah thomas
is a man
emma wyatt won the 500
so says florida governor ron desantis
for far too long sanity has been content
to point
and mock insanity we've trusted that
reality would reward and permit
sanity to prevail
we were children of the enlightenment we
thought logic and reason would win the
day but america is sliding into a new
dark ages one where racism is approved
if it's called
anti-racism one where science means thou
shalt not question fauci and one where
men are women and women are men
we've talked about the need to create
parallel systems to create tech
companies where censorship
is not
the rule
to create
companies large corporations
entrepreneurial small businesses
that don't approve of sexualizing
children
and of finding states that are free from
anti-scientific
lockdowns
the idea is
you shouldn't participate
in a system or with a company that hates
you you shouldn't participate
in a fraud that's what florida governor
ron desantis said that florida will not
participate in the fraud that leah
thomas is a man
and participate in the destruction of
women's sports
good
don't participate
don't pretend don't participate opt out
find companies
play sports
not ruled by
insanity it would be best if all the
women swimmers in the ncaa just walked
out
wouldn't pretend wouldn't participate
and find
parallel systems
that's what governor ron desantis
has done leah thomas is not your
champion emma wyant
is
the champ
this is will kane host of the will kane
podcast which you can find by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
america is listening to fox news
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes